[Musica]
[Risate]
tutto bene
ho sentito un rumore strano provenire
d'acqua rottami combinando è farò perché
siamo nel periodo di halloween mi
immagino i suoni poi ci sono bellissime
giornate ovvero merlino
circe sei tu
e spaventata
qui sotto il letto e guardate conto è
diventata grande sirce è grandissimo
e grandissima jeans
che stai guardando la sua
che strano che continua a guardare la
sopra
come se ci fosse qualcosa lassù dove
avrò visto qualche fantasma come mie
origini di oggi dei fantasmini vi
piacciono e da un po che non vedo non
sento vitale secondo voi cosa sta
facendo il gelso starà ma intanto ti
nascosto ma cosa starà pensando vitale
ciao dì la verità che cosa stavi
mangiando di nascosto come sempre io
mangiando di nascosto non ho questa
volta giuro che non stavo proprio
mangiando niente granocchiaio è calata
me l'aveva sgranocchiare non è mangiare
sgranocchi qualcosa così ma noi che
mangi proprio ma che cos'è quello che
cosa questo sul cuore
cpt no non l'ho scritto io forse ne hai
scritto tu io e perché avrei dovuto
scrivere io ci ho t non sono le mie
iniziali non sono le tue iniziali non
sono neanche le iniziali di cibo
cavatelli paroli si trovi mi piacciono
ma insomma la smetti per momento di
pensare al cibo e mi dici che cosa
significa cpt dono gli iniziali di
qualcuno o iscritto in un cuore
probabilmente sono anche fidanzati
ti ricordi la challenge delle porte
c'erano vari personaggi cielo forse
qualche personaggio che si chiamava ceo
qualche personaggio che si chiamava atti
ice cream che si chiama anche rob che il
lupo non credo ci fosse qualcuno con le
iniziali cio che non mi viene in mente
niente iniziali erano già lì quando
l'hai comprato non credo fossero già qui
quando l'ho comprato me ne sarei
ricordato ora lo terrò sotto
osservazione anzi lo lascio qua nel
frattempo merlino e circe sono diventati
un pochino amici dai diciamo che
si sopportano tutte e due berline ad
ormea tantissimo come sempre e ci si
prova sempre a giocare con berlino ma
berlino vuole dormire
beh allora se non hai problemi qui a
rimanere da sola io porto berlino a fare
una passeggiata fuori ok andiamo berlino
che dovrei avere problemi a rimanere qua
da sola non sono sola sono con te
lasciate un mi piace per portarmi
fortuna
cliccate mi piace qua sotto ho sentito
un rumore che proveniva dalla sopra
anche se non dovrei andare a controllare
da solo e dovrei aspettare che torni
vitale andiamo a controllare
mi ero dimenticata che non vi ho fatto
vedere le nuove piante più comprato
perché io adoro le piante a dover
comprare le piante guardate questa è una
pianta di ananas
nei mesi questo anno adesso piccoli in
miniatura è carinissimo che umiliano
notte bellissimo
circe quante volte ti ho detto che non
puoi arrampicarti suoi pantaloni si
circe si arrampica sui pantaloni come la
scimmietta guardò tenore carinissima
questa mini anas e troppo carino
e poi l'altra pianta che ho comprato e
questa corratec è bella perché questa
pianta si chiama anche anita non mi
ricordo il nome per trarre tipo bwr
ammaliati l'ansia anita
verifichiamo anche anita quindi non
potevo non comprarla
è meglio che mi sbrigo a controllare
questa cella sopra
c'è nessuno nascosto qua ho sentito
qualcosa
strano non vedo niente di strano
ci sono sempre i miei soliti pupazzi
eppure mi è sembrato di sentire delle
risate circe hai sentito qualcuno laggiù
berlino che cosa ci fai qua non eri
fuori un mondiale
strano
berlino sei stato tu a disegnare questo
che cos'è un teschio con le ossa può
essere stato solo berlino a meno che
vitale non mi stia facendo uno scherzo e
sia nascosto da qualche parte vitale 6
nascosto dove sei non sembra che sia
come vitale non può essere stato berlino
con il naso come fa anzi vediamo se
berlino riesce a disegnare con il naso
dai merlino vai disegna
berlino sta disegnando con il naso
realmente ma come da berlino a disegnare
un teschio questa se tutti segnato
qualcosa sembra un cuore con una freccia
o forse vuole solo prendere l'osso del
teschio e è anche giusto e vuole
rimediare se volete di segnare tutti e
due
vitale 6 giu che mi stai facendo uno
scherzo
avete visto
sono passate due bambole la sotto
le favole
ehi tu dov'eri sono fuori in giardino
con berlino perchè questo è successo non
è vero che lì fuori in giardino con
berlino perché berlino è rientrato senza
di te sì ma io sono rientrato in casa
adesso sono rimasto un po fuori in
giardino mi stai facendo uno scherzo
vero perché dovrei farti uno scherzo no
ho visto due bambole ho paura che in
tempo per il periodo di halloween siano
tornate le bambole cattive ma no da il
tesoro è sbagliata a una prova per te
nascondiamoci qua in casa nascondiamoci
anche noi vediamo se saltano fuori
bene allora scegliamo il nostro
nascondiglio
io vedo come cugino madonnina toglierti
quali questa camere che avrei capito le
regole del gioco aspetto devo prendere
[Musica]
no non lo vedo io come nascondiglio
scelgo sotto il letto lì sicuramente non
vi troveranno e tu invece non nascondono
dietro la tenda così non mi verranno
pensa che ti vengano là dietro e uniti
qua infatto angolino che ne dite un bel
nascondiglio questo occorre no
rilasciato che mi piace se vi piace il
mio nascondiglio
bene non nascondiamoci e aspettiamo
non farmi scoprire con una posta 48 ok
no no non tirare la coperta no
eccoli
parte meglio la mia sposta qua e vitale
vitale ei ma
ma che sta facendo
non mi dire che sia tormentato
cristiana ci sarà una bambola ei
ma che stanno facendo
vitale
ma
che dici non far rumore
stiamo qui nascosti
dobbiamo dobbiamo scoprire che dobbiamo
fare non mi ricordo più come cosa
dobbiamo fare tu eri nascosto per vedere
le bambole le favole erano quasi leto
che spettavano sbaciucchiato comunque
sono più uscite fuori dalla porta viene
riguarda
le bambole ci hanno chiuso a chiave
dentro la camera
il bravo il momento giusto per
addormentarti avresti potuto farle lo
sgambetto prenderle e buttarla fuori
dalla finestra quanto io non avevo
capito pensavo che dovevamo solo
nasconderci aspettare e ma cosa è quello
e aspetta circe
un biglietto
vediamo cosa c'è scritto
la casa e nostra adesso voi rimarrete
chiusi qua per sempre perdenti
si più
tcp utile letta che c'erano nel cuscino
guarda c'è qualcos'altro si cosa
ma
vitale d'ora in poi
che ti piace mangiare e dicono che d'ora
in poi tu starai colpite
non è per niente divertente guarda
dobbiamo subito trovare un piano per
scappare subito subito ora ti interessa
scappare dopo che sei stato minacciato
con quest'immagine
quelli tra la forza che ci sta un
ascoltano
[Musica]